and yeah you know the acronym is really
based on
like your consistency of posting you
know it it
it very it goes up and down you know
with the amount of views that you get
and the likes and the
the you know the comments and you know
the engage that you get with your fans
you know that it just plays a balance
but big thing is knowing when the post
and is that through like analytics
yeah analytics show you okay you know
they tell you the best time the post but
it's like i've found
without their analytics i found the best
time for me
that's that's good and like that's been
consistent for me
which is 7 15 you know for the people
you know so how did you find that number
for yourself are you tracking
are you keeping notes of like okay i
posted a six
this week i posted it at 6 00 p.m on
sunday did okay
oh this week i posted at seven did even
better
it's just like yeah it's just like that
and it was at a point where i was
posting at like 8 39
which it was cool uh but
it would be like some people will
probably be off some people be asleep
you know so i'm like nah that's probably
not not good
so i dropped down to 7 15 is like
it's like that that right interesting
that right
you know the right time of the day
you know some people just got off work
you know
some people may be laying in the bed
some people
i don't you know is it that right
they're right i feel like you said
right that sweet spot you know for me
you know and then it's it's really
it's just some water too yeah it's
really some of that water it's really um
knowing your fans age range as well okay
you know so my biggest range i would say
is from like
uh
21 to like
25. is this instagram yeah okay but
you know i still have like 30 you know
but like the biggest is probably like 21
to 25 that's like my
biggest range and knowing
that there are young people you know
what i'm saying so it's like
that that that black level at 7 15 is
like the the thing
and it's a different i think that's
another good note is knowing who your
audience is so
your audience may be 715 my audience
maybe exactly comedians that are out at
a show at 9 00 p.m
exactly just knowing when that is and
maybe
a weekend evening maybe a good time to
post a video
as maybe a tuesday morning is better to
post like an image
or something like that too most
definitely see with images
i probably said it was good as you said
it with images i post around about
i would say 11 in the morning 12. you
know
those good for images you know just some
they could just scroll
you know and just you know especially in
the morning
you know in the morning it just depends
on what the video is i mean people ain't
trying to
and then maybe it worked yeah yeah yeah
you know if it's a picture it's just
like oh but you know
it might be a word that can't listen to
it i can't laugh i didn't say i watch
this later and when i get off or
something
you know you know it's something like
that so yeah
what about facebook like it seems like
we're just about instagram what about
facebook is the same i
i when i post some on instagram i post
it all i post
i go i actually post it on twitter first
huh yeah
interesting you know it's like crazy i
found the thing too
see twitter is like my test
you know i post it on twitter first and
if i see twitter
is doing good on twitter okay i know
exactly what it's going to do on
instagram i know exactly what it's going
to do on facebook i know exactly what
it's going to do on youtube
so if you don't do it on it if it only
give me my good feeling on twitter i
don't post it
so it's like it's like a cheat sheet
uh-huh you know what i'm saying
like that's what kind of like keep me
safe you know i post it on twitter first
okay if it's let's say for example like
50 retweets in 67 minutes that's
phenomenal on my twitter page
you know so if i see that it's like okay
oh it's going to be a good video on
instagram i'm not even going to worry
about it facebook i know it's going to
do good you know what i'm saying
now if it's like 15
retweets in six minutes ah i'm not
posting that
i'm not posting that one you know but
it's like a cc i mean you know that's
nice
yeah it's like a beta tester yeah yeah
testing if it's worth going
most definitely to the skyway most
definitely can this get off the runway
before we throw it off the cliff there
you go
so yeah twitter is like that that cheat
sheet for me
to like you know before i post anything
so how important are captions in all
that game
oh it's big that's what they're yeah
cause they're they're looking at that
caption before they even watch the video
interesting yeah so if it gotta be it
gotta pop to the people
it has to pop to the people so yeah how
do you make it pop to the people
um this is depending on what you're
saying like what i would say for
okay baby mom video um
when your baby mama steer your money
or it's still key word when your baby
mama
whoop your son or when your baby it just
you know it can't just be when your baby
mama
when you're tripping it's going to be
like an action yeah yeah
yeah tripping yeah yeah yeah
like take the d yeah
it's those key words that make him go
watch uh-huh
you know gotcha so watch that caption
pop
okay boom i can watch it now yeah it but
it's got to be concise i see some people
do like paragraphs do you
depend on the following it just depends
on your following yeah it just depends
um yeah it depends on the following
i mean i've i've been straight straight
up with my you know
straight up simple boom post you know
so but with um with the content uh
not limit content length instagram 60
seconds
what length of video do you find works
for like a facebook
[Music]
hot breath